today's topic robert downey jr
so if you aren't aware robert downey jr
was on the joe rogan podcast
last week and talked about his role in
tropic thunder
in which he played an australian actor
in blackface
and in doing so talking about it
casually
the clip went viral a whole bunch of
news media outlets
picked it up and they started dragging
robert downey jr for
acting in blackface
you mentioned robert downey jr um
you know i've talked to a bunch of
people about about the robert downey jr
role in entropic thunder you know robert
downey jr did blackface
and no one was really upset because i
was upset i did it
pretty oh you were upset i was clearly
upset yeah
that's why i brought that up okay why is
that
it's just not fair man i think you know
they like to pull
the wool over our eyes sometimes and
make us think that something is cool
because
a certain person is doing it but
blackface is blackface it was used as a
tool to oppress
black people because they didn't want to
see our faces on stage
and it should never be duplicated or
replicated
i don't know if this guy watched the
movie blackface is the erasure of black
people
using a white character to substitute
for a black character
robert downey jr wasn't playing a black
character he was playing a white
actor act one of the co-stars is a black
person who constantly calls him out
on his attempt at trying to be so you
have both sides of it and my thing is
this is clearly entertainment this is
clearly meant to talk about a specific
topic and my question is
if i want to bring up blackface if i
want to represent the history of america
that involves blackface
how do i represent blackface on stage
without getting a white character to be
in blackface
if i was to get a black character in
blackface it would defeat the purpose
because it's not blackface
it would be like saying because the fact
that slave happened
that you can't show black people in
chains
listen i think you guys have taken this
way further than it needs to go
it's not that deep it's really not you
guys have to separate
not every time that you get pulled over
by a cop that is because of
sometimes you were going too fast okay
an actor is actually just embodying the
role it's never acceptable
it's never funny how dare he you know
how unfair
yes he's trying to highlight how unfair
it is that's why the black character is
also present because he calls him out on
how unfair it is
y'all don't give a [ __ ] about context
you just don't
like y'all see a headline and you don't
click to read the article like you guys
see a book and you look at the title on
the cover and you walk away
you guys think you've understood it just
off the title i'm like no you gotta
i actually went to go watch the movie
because i'm like what are y'all talking
about and i watch it i'm like are you
guys dumb
are you guys dumb if you
yeah genuinely i got so upset when i
finished the movie because not only was
i laughing but i'm like
how can you guys be this dumb they're
they're too busy being pissed off and
triggered
that they forgot about the fact that
that's exactly what they're talking
about not only you're saying that
white people cannot do whiteface but
white people cannot even talk about it
because them talking about it is them
using their white privilege and this and
that like they're making fun of that
they're saying that that
is ridiculous rough i'm starting to
think that there's a fake outrage
machine somewhere out there
and they're just manufacturing stuff oh
there is it's built by the media it's
built by a lot of things
built out of people i would be convinced
i would be convinced that it is that in
this case
if it wasn't for the fact that i know
dumb people like this in real life
yeah of course plenty they are part of
the machine
that makes this thing going you
understand what i'm saying
that's what it is i know people like
that and like i got
all the crayons that i can use all the
diagrams and stuff like that to explain
them what it was
and how it is not that but they don't
care people do not care about context
they don't they don't give it it's too
demanding it's just
i got triggered and i'm right because if
it feels bad
it's bad well you know it's not because
you feel like you're following that
you're actually falling maybe you're in
a roller coaster you understand
it's not real danger it's really easy
and lazy to just go like oh that's what
happened and not
look at the context because it takes
some time and intelligence to understand
what was happening because you have to
dissect
if you just get the things right there
in your face and you just base yourself
on that then of course you fall into the
trap and then boom there you go
you triggered and there there goes an
outrage and stuff like that you know we
were talking about this the other day we
you have to have a comedy intelligence
you have to have the intelligence to
decipher stuff with this
first degree second degree you know
there's some people that are incapable
of
understanding sarcasm uh there's people
that are not
able to understand first degree second
degree yeah that's part of that
that's the level of the comedy
intelligence that happens and people
don't rely on that it's too demanding
all right well that's it for today's
video tell us what you guys think about
this whole issue
we want to hear from you guys do you
really
this is a dumb issue this is just an
issue
they're trying to make a thing outside
of something that's not a thing
[Music]
you